speaking of Saturday Night Live since I
last didn't you host the Christmas
special right yeah Amy and I hosted
brick right after I was here last right
and then it was there was something odd
that happened there
there was a Bruce Springsteen with the
musical guest which is exciting right
yeah because you get to sit there and
watch him you know rehearse and all that
and you hang with him at all you know we
did actually this time sort of talked to
them after the party I I'm very shy like
I don't want to talk to that we never
would try to like talk to the host of
musical guests back when I worked there
but I really did you you don't go up to
the musical guest and say hey I really
liked what you did already I was always
so shy you know but yeah we got roped
into sort of singing with them at the
end of the show they were like they're
gonna they want you to go up and sing uh
they're gonna sing Santa Claus is coming
to town
you and Amy go up and shake jingle bells
I was like oh yeah sure sure sure and
then we got up there and we were shaking
the jingle bells and they were like like
calling us up to the mic and I was like
is this a trick I was like terrifying
and so they kept and was dressed they
kept being like come up here so finally
we got up in the mic and I just was
trying to like I'm saying okay I'm on
Bruce Springsteen's mic so obviously
this mic is hot yeah nobody wants to
hear me right so I kept trying to like
move my face a lot like not they're not
nerd sounding like trying to make his
little sound as possible right and does
he call you out on that does he say well
come on sing up they made fun of us
between the dressers on the live show
they were like why are you all so shy
they were laughing at us because it's
Bruce Springsteen and you don't want to
[ __ ] it up for the audience exactly they
don't want to see me do that no as much
as I like me was on stage no it's not
but the weird thing was but did you
notice that Paul McCartney didn't sing
either like he was up on stage and he
clearly didn't know what to do why he
never heard that song before he's from
England he had no idea it was the most
interesting dynamic to me
he did use platelets he just play jingle
bells no he just kind of stood there
looking like well I'm Paul McCartney I'm
Paul McCartney I think Paul heard you
singing quietly and he took his cue from
you
was that fun for you hosting that
Christmas that was fun yeah and you
brought back Sarah Palin yes which is
hard for you to do because you keep
forgetting the accent you told me look
comes goes one this time I did it tough
like I did it once when we hosted and
then I became back another time because
after she endorsed Donald Trump there
they asked me to come back in right I
felt like I had to start over and
relearn learn it like a new impression
cuz she's different
she's a little it's a little less you
know jacked up yeah in other words her
accent has changed just like um I feel
like is she drinking a lot of Red Bull
like really pumped up anyway so did you
have to speed up the impression yeah it
was like she was just like really kind
of manic in that thing with him and and
also I suspect maybe you know eight
years ago the speech writers the McCain
speech writers were writing for her and
now she's running or herself and I guess
when you do an impression yeah you don't
you want to keep up with the times
people don't change I watched that 20
minute that tape where she endorsed
Donald Trump she talked for 20 minutes
Wow you can watch his face during it I
watch it like ten times he goes from
being really really psyched that he is
burning Ted Cruz by her endorsement and
then over the course of it he's like a
long way talking too long I want to go
home I'm the one that talks